CONNIE HUANG: So this
semester we were working on
[? Clampe, ?] which is an
iPhone mount for the wheelchair.
And the kind of special
thing about [? Clampe ?]
was there are
iPhone mounts, there
are plenty of
iPhone accessories,
but the client we
were working with
had kind of a special range
of abilities and disabilities.
So what we were building
for the wheelchair
was not only a
mount, but also one
that could accommodate his range
of motion and his strength.
And it ended up
being something that
was flexible enough
for him and his needs,
and still allowed him
the kind of independence
that he wanted in
every day interaction.
VINEEL CHAKRADHAR: So I've
actually done a bit of work
in assistive
technology in the past,
and it's always
really interested me.
I think that working
on assistive technology
is one of the best things
that an engineer can work on,
both because the problem
is quite interesting,
and because every engineer
wants to build something
that helps people and this
is one of the best avenues
to do that.
NATASHA GUNTHER: OK, so the way
this class was presented to me
was a course six
class that dealt
with a client with a
disability, and I was like,
oh, I'm course two, obviously
I have no place there.
But what I was told
was actually that you
can come from completely
different backgrounds,
the main concept is that
you have a direct impact
on someone's life throughout
the course of a semester, which
is something almost
incomprehensible.
And I think you can only get
a course at MIT as real life
basis in helping a person.
VINEEL CHAKRADHAR: So
coming into the class,
I actually didn't even
have enough information
to build expectation almost.
I just knew that it was going
to be an interesting opportunity
to work on an actual
applied problem.
And the first few years
that I spent at MIT,
I worked on a lot of
theoretical problems,
both in like coursework
and things of that sort.
And I thought this would be
a really cool opportunity
to, like, take my skills and
things that I've learned here,
and work on a real project
with a real person.
I did learn quite a few things
that were unexpected, actually.
In class, there's--
I don't know,
you're kind of taught that
the things that are, like,
most complex are the most
grand in a large sense.
But when you're working
with real people,
you tend to sacrifice
complexity to make things work.
Almost where you might
be in a situation
where, like, a solution that
takes you a thousand times
longer to implement might
be marginally better,
but like in the interest
of time and speed
and moving the process
forward, you're
going to go for a
simpler solution.
The thing I learned
from that process
is that you constantly
have to modify what it
is you are actually working on.
Because at the end
of the day, it's
not so much about being
given a problem statement
that explicitly lists
everything you have to do,
but more about
building something
that your client wants.
And the biggest
thing we learned is
that those desires
can change over time,
so it's more
important, not-- it's
more important, to work on
what the client actually wants,
and build something that you
think he or she will actually
use, as opposed to
being fixated on what,
like, the initial project
proposal was to a sense.
NATASHA GUNTHER: Vineel
touched on this a bit earlier,
but through a team dynamic
and working in multiple
vary-- iterations
of our design, we
found that assumptions are
the most dangerous thing.
And when you're moving
through various iterations,
a full 180 degrees
pivot is not something
to be afraid of because that
can save your entire project,
and we found that
it actually did.
We made a lot of
assumptions initially about
our client Aaron's
abilities or disabilities,
and we found we
were compensating
for a problem he never even had
originally, so we did a pivot
and created an item
that he would actually
be able to use and enjoy using.
Each disability has
so many variations.
Aaron defines his
paraplegia as C5 slash 6.
And there's so many
ranges of paraplegia,
and he doesn't even fit
within one grade of it,
so I think that gives
you a little bit
of an idea of how different
each person's disability can be.
And defining your assistive
technology for just that one
person is the most
important aspect,
because they're your client.
But I think on a
grander scale, we
saw a problem within
assistive technology
is making it accessible to
as many people as possible
while still satisfying
that disability.
I'd say that's a great
challenge in assistive tech.
VINEEL CHAKRADHAR:
The blogs gave us
a lot of context,
because to a large degree
the posts could
be about anything.
And this was important because
we know that we are engineers,
and sometimes when you're
working on these problems,
when you get too deep
into it, you almost
forget why it is
you're doing this.
And I guess the biggest
thing that the blogs did
for me is that after a day spent
in, like, the machine shop,
or a day spent
brainstorming design ideas,
you could go to the blog and
just read articles about people
with disabilities, the
struggles that they faced,
how people are looking to
combat those struggles,
and it kind of gives you a
renewed sense of motivation.
NATASHA GUNTHER:
I'd say it's very
important for the
professor to realize
that we may have no experience
with user centered design.
I know these two did, actually,
but I personally did not.
And when it's about
your client, it's
a lot less about what design
process you are you used to,
and a lot more about
what the client wants
to receive from you at
the end of the semester.
So focusing a lot on client,
not making assumptions,
and-- I think the professors
did a very good job this course,
though.